despite americans reputation for being
cockeyed optimists we've always been
suckers for declension narratives or
stories about how the golden age ended
sometime in the past
and we have the right luck to live in a
world that is no longer what it once was
donald trump built a successful
presidential campaign on making america
great again
and his successor joe biden's build back
better slogan
similarly harkens back to a more
wholesome and idyllic past
we often hear of falling fertility rates
rising income inequality
and declining economic mobility but
these stories are either misleading
or flat out wrong it's a one-year cut
that reduces your taxes by
three thousand dollars a year for each
child you have under the age of 18. both
democrats and republicans are pushing
for new subsidies for parents
attributing our historically low
fertility rates
to the cost of raising kids joe biden's
american rescue plan gives parents of
toddlers as much as 3 600
annually for each child and josh hawley
wants to up that to 12 grand
though only for married couples but the
reason we're having fewer kids isn't
because they cost too much
it's because we don't want as many as we
used to look at the trend in fertility
which is dramatically down
across the industrialized world and to
understand it
is it a problem because people actually
would like to have more kids but can't
afford to scott winship is a sociologist
and the director of poverty studies at
the american enterprise institute or aei
he argues that if it's a lack of money
that's swaying americans to procreate
less then we'll find that a growing
number of women will have had to scale
back the number of kids they planned on
having in their early 20s and that's not
the case winship points to a bureau of
labor statistics survey which found that
44
of millennial women ended up having
fewer children than they had expected as
young adults
29 had more and 27
hit their targets exactly but the same
survey conducted on baby boomers born a
generation earlier
found that today's women are actually
slightly more likely to reach or exceed
their parental dreams
indicating that declining birth rates
mostly reflect a cultural shift as a
society we've chosen more
stuff and fewer kids turns out women
have been better able
to achieve their fertility targets even
though a lot of them haven't even
started having kids yet
when says that simple morality tells
about a massive and growing gap between
the wealthiest
and the poorest americans missed more
important truths
inequality has increased over the past
half century
but low-income americans have made
massive gains
especially when you take into account
their after-tax
income and transfers the ginny
coefficient a measure of income
inequality has basically been the same
since 1989
and overall poverty child poverty and
poverty among the kids of single mothers
are at
all-time lows as important he notes
middle-class americans have seen their
income
rise dramatically when you're talking
about the median household you're
looking at an income of around
70 000 that's up something like 25
000 since 1979 for instance that's
taking into account the fact that prices
have gone up for all the things we buy
not working harder than we used to we
just have 25 000
more at the middle than our counterparts
did but what about the ability to move
up the income ladder from where you
started which for many people defines
the american dream
it's common to read headlines announcing
that millennials are the first
generation will be poorer than their
parents
and they comprise a new lost generation
these claims are flatly wrong
since when [ __ ] i've sort of looked at
the data and found that's probably
closer to 70 percent
uh of of kind of 30 year olds today
are better off than their parents were
winship believes that part of the
problem is that
people spreading these narratives of
generational decline
come from a narrow slice of contemporary
society
i have a theory about in addition to
just kind of this declensionism that
sort of runs through all this stuff
i think that you hear more about this
because a lot of people in media
are upper middle class but they were
also raised
uh pretty upper middle class themselves
um
so there is downward mobility and that
that that is a thing um
uh there are there are people who do
worse than their parents it's more
likely if your parents were rich
uh that you're gonna do worse than than
them winship stresses that anything we
do that slows down risk-taking and
innovation is not only likely to hurt
our long-term economic growth
but also increase demand for government
policies that will
save us leaving us with the worst of two
possible outcomes
a smaller economy and a bigger
government
you